- You've done it before right?
- Nah.
- No?
- Never.
- Get it, yeah.
(everyone cheering)
- (clapping) Up, up, up, up!
- [Narrator] If you had to
rank yourself against others
based on a specific trait,
what would it say about how you see them,
and how they see you?
To find out, we brought together five men
and had them rank each other
based on their perceived strength.
Then, we put them to the test
to reveal their actual strength.
This is "Ranking".
(graphic pulsing)
- As cliche and corny it is
to say, and I hate saying it,
working out is a lifestyle.
- [Voice Over] Bruh!
- I schedule my workouts
and it's kind of like,
oh, Isaac do you wanna do this?
I'm like, okay, I gotta make sure
it's not interfering with my workout time.
- Yeah, I would say it
would be my main hobby.
It's something, every day
that you look forward to doing.
- I would say it's between
working out and gaming.
- What got you into working out
and what got you into lifting heavy?
- I started actually weight lifting,
when I was in high school.
I had the reputation of being
the guy that was bigger.
Just kind of kept that going.
It's become like a part of my personality.
- I've always been involved with sports,
wrestling, football.
I started power lifting as
of very recently though.
- Yeah, I was also in eighth
grade, it during the summer.
And I was at a pool party
with all my friends.
We were just jumping up and down the pool,
just having a great time,
and then one of the girls that
I had a crush on was like,
"Hey Edward, carry me!
Throw me into the pool!"
I was like, alright!
(everyone laughs)
I got this girl,
just going to the pool, about
to go in and she's like,
"Oh my God, Edward!
stop, stop!"
I'm just like, "Oh, what happened?"
And she's like, "You're shaking so much,
I don't feel comfortable
in your arms right now."
I'm just like, oh man.
After that, I just went home,
(loud guitar plays)
(everyone laughs)
Working out man.
- What about you?
- I'm sorry.
(Angel chuckles)
When I was pretty young, I
got very into video games
and I started playing "Star
Wars" and "Lara Croft."
- What really got me into it was,
I was actually bullied ever
since I was in elementary
'cause I was always a bigger, taller kid.
And all my friends were
like, "Oh dude, Isaac,
you're so big, I bet you're so strong."
And then they would actually
end up physically hurting me.
I didn't know what to do,
and so as I got older, in middle school
that's when I was like,
okay, I gotta change something.
And so I started lifting then.
When I squat, bench, deadlift
as heavy as possible,
that's when I feel really empowered.
- Oh yeah, I'm so sorry about that,
that happened to you
because no one should be
shamed for how they look.
(graphic swishing)
- Just to put it out there,
I think I'm just gonna rank
myself as the least strongest.
Oh my God, Edward, stop,
you're shaking so much.
- I will go that way too.
- I don't want to be here (chuckles)
- For me, I think it's between you two.
- Nah (chuckles).
- I feel like you, you just
have a lot of knowledge
and you know a lot, and your motivation.
I just feel like you're out there.
But then you just, look at your quads bro.
- Look at his calves.
- Look at your calves.
- Wait, can you show off your quads?
- His calf is the size
of my thighs, I mean.
- These are genetic.
- Bro you could crush watermelons
with those quads, man.
- I think you should be in the front
and then you should be right behind him.
- If you wanna put me in the front
you're gonna have to make me.
You're gonna have to
actually physically move me.
- I don't think I can do that (laughs).
(Isaac laughs)
- I think it's between you two to be.
- Well, okay.
- Yeah.
- If we're talking raw
strength, muscle mass,
genetically, I feel like
I'm just not built to lift.
I literally had to eat
800 grams of carbs a day
to get to where I am now,
and it took a long time.
- But that's the thing,
you're focused on that.
Your life's focused on that-
- Exactly.
And I'm not.
- [Brandon] We can see the progress,
so, get up there, buddy.
- Oh, I feel like I
shouldn't be right here.
It's not for me!
- You see, but there's a problem
that I have with it that,
I mean, looks aren't
everything but you look strong.
And it's like, it can be deceiving.
That's why I feel like, if
we have a clear definition
on what we are defining strength as.
- We're also gonna test
ourselves with deadlifts.
- Deadlifts.
- So I think we should
rank ourself with that.
- So we could rank ourselves with that.
- Alright, so who do we think
is going to deadlift the most?
- How do you feel being there?
- I feel like we should switch.
- I actually feel like the
raw power and the raw strength
that you have without the technique,
if we just compare that,
I feel like either of you
two are stronger than me.
- Hmm, I'm very unsure of that.
- I don't agree to be honest, but.
- For him to be in the
middle, I don't agree.
- I don't agree.
- You didn't sell me on that one.
- I think Isaac should
stay number one though,
and then I think these two should switch.
- I agree with that.
- Can I actually ask, what
do you do for a living?
- Military.
- Military, got it.
And what do you do for a living?
- I'm a mail carrier.
- Mail carrier.
- Yeah.
- Well that's pretty
good too, I don't know.
But you guys walk a lot, and all that.
- Well, I feel like mail
carriers can be strong
because there's still a
lot of lifting involved.
- Yeah.
- With packages and stuff.
- That's a lot
- But military?
Army or army marines?
- You wouldn't guess it (chuckles).
- Oh, Okay.
- Space.
- Got it.
(whimsical music)
Well you're still jacked as hell man.
(all laughing)
so that's something.
- Yo, you gotta find aliens.
- Yeah!
I think switch.
- Okay.
- Switch, yeah.
- I also, I'm thinking because
I've been doing CrossFit
since last year, maybe I
do have a good technique
for what we're gonna do.
- Um-hm.
- And I feel like you already
have a very strong base.
Maybe switch you two?
- But what do you do?
Do you do gym?
- I would agree with that.
- I do power lifting.
- Oh, power lifting.
- Yeah.
- That's why I think he might-
But you said you started recently, right?
- Yes.
- Uh, Yeah.
- Okay.
- Can I see your squat?
- Sure.
(upbeat music)
- Hmm.
- I wanna say switch.
- Yeah me too.
- I would switch you two.
- I'm sorry.
It's just because you're curved.
- No, you're good.
- Oh yeah, cool.
- Yours, it's just gonna be perfect.
- Let's start with you.
- No, no, no!
(upbeat music)
(knee pops)
(Isaac grunts)
- You got a crack in there.
- You're the guts.
(hands and knees clapping)
(upbeat music)
- Um-hm.
(upbeat music continues)
- Solid.
- Well, you got a wide base.
- Yeah.
- I mean he's got a long legs, so.
- I think we're good.
- Oh, hey good humans.
Before we continue, we
wanna say a quick thank you
to our sponsor of this
episode, Warby Parker.
Warby Parker is committed
to providing exceptional vision
care online and in stores,
offering eyeglasses,
sunglasses, eye exams,
and contact lenses.
They offer a great range of stylish frames
that start at $95, including
prescription lenses.
Plus they've got sunglasses, progressives,
and blue light lenses available too.
What I like about Warby
Parker is how easy it is
to find the right pair of glasses.
After answering just a
few questions online,
Warby Parker will suggest some glasses
that fit your face and style.
With their home try-on kit,
you can order five pairs
of glasses and try them on
for five days with absolutely
no obligation to buy.
They ship for free and include
a prepaid return label,
so it's totally easy.
Glasses, I think, are
a very personal thing.
So I love being able to try on a few pairs
to see what looks best
and get feel for them
before actually committing.
Again, try five pairs of
glasses at home for free
at warbyparker.com/jubilee.
Now enjoy the episode.
(graphic swishing)
- I think my max is
gonna be around 280, 290.
- Okay.
(upbeat music)
(weights banking)
- Dude, you can lift that with one hand?
- The way you were squatting
there, man you got this.
- Yeah!
- Let's go!
(men cheering)
(bell dings)
- Oh you got moves!
You got moves!
(men clapping hands)
- Was that a sumo?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So-
- Alright, I just want to add a 10.
- Okay.
- I think that's my max right there.
- Wait, is this about to be a PR?
- I've only done this once before.
- Hey, you're about to
do it a second time.
- Yeah.
- [Isaac] Take your time.
- Let's get it, let's
get it, let's get it.
- [Isaac] Yup.
(upbeat energetic music)
- Lock in.
- Come on.
(upbeat energetic music)
- Yup!
Yup!
(men cheering and clapping)
- Okay, okay.
(men continue cheering and clapping)
(bell dings)
- [Isaac] All right.
- [Brandon] Easy with it.
- All right.
- A little bit of pressure here.
- Hey, easy boy!
Let's go, let's go!
- You're about to apply pressure.
- Yeah, come on!
- [Ruben] Let's go!
Hardcore, baby!
- [Brandon] Let's get it, let's get it!
- Come on, come on!
- [Isaac] Easy!
(constants and crew cheering and clapping)
- Okay!
Yup!
- Yup, yup!
- Yeah, dude!
_ Alright!
(bell dings)
You're goin' up, right?
- I think.
- Yeah!
- I told you dawg-
(Isaac clapping)
- I'm sorry, I didn't
know that I could do this.
It's the first time.
- That's a PR?
(cheering)
- Whoa!
- Let's go!
- Let's get it!
(upbeat music)
- 335.
(upbeat music continues)
(hands clapping)
- Come on, easy work!
Lock it it!
[Brandon] There you go!
- [Isaac] Up, up, up!
Come on!
- Up, up, up!
- All the way up!
- There you go!
There you go!
(men cheering and clapping)
- [Isaac] Easy work!
(bell dings)
- You got more!
You got more!
You're going up!
You think you could do it?
I don't wanna push you too much.
- Five.
- Five?
Okay, okay.
- Y'all did this to me (laughs).
(hands clapping)
- All right, boys.
You gotta hype up the hell up.
Wait, he's ready?
- Ready for what.
(men cheering)
(hands clapping)
- Let's go!
(men cheering)
- You got this easy work.
- [Isaac] Easy work.
Easy work!
Yup, yup, yup!
Let's go, let's go, let's go!
(men cheering and clapping)
(bell dings)
- That's a 60 pound jump.
- Yeah.
- That's massive.
- Well, that's a 60 pound PR.
- We push each other out.
- Thank you so much guys.
- All right, we got you.
- Everyone (chuckles).
- My turn?
- We'll throw on 10s.
(upbeat music)
(weights clicking)
- You've done it before, right?
- Nah.
- No?
- Never.
- [Isaac] PR?
- Yeah, this will be a PR.
- Let's get it, dude!
- [Isaac] Yes, sir!
- Let's get it.
- Whoa!
- Come on!
- Let's go!
- Let's go's good!
'Bout to lift that!
- [Isaac] Yup!
Yup!
- [Brandon] Light weight.
- [Brandon] Let's move that!
- [Isaac] Yup!
- Come on!
- [Brandon] Let's move that one.
- Get it!
- Yeah!
- All the way, yup!
- All the way!
- Up, up, up, up!
Move it al the way!
(all cheering and clapping)
- There we go!
(all continue cheering and clapping)
(bell dings)
- Yeah!
(Isaac cheers)
- I don't know if it's weird to say it,
but you have a thick back.
You have a thick back when you deadlift.
- We both did record.
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
- Oh yeah.
- Dude, I'm telling you,
this guy's got raw power.
- I honestly think you can
deadlift more than me today.
- You need a slap.
- I'm gonna need a slap.
- Woo!
This guy got a lot of muscle.
Come on!
(hands clap)
- [Ruben] There.
(Brandon cheers)
- [Edward] Light weight baby!
- Easy work!
- Yep, yep!
- [Ruben] Lock in.
Come on.
- Yup, yup, yup!
Come on!
(all cheering)
up, up, up, up!
Come on!
Up!
Got it, got it, got it, got it!
(all continue cheering)
(weight banging)
(bell dings)
(Isaac and Ruben clapping hands)
- 475.
- Easy work.
- I didn't expect him to
just be so much stronger.
- Let's go five plates.
- It's a lot of weight, and
he about to make it look easy.
(chuckles) I'm telling you.
- He's like carrying in weight, all of us.
- There's a lot of
pressure here (chuckles).
- [Ruben] Let's go, man.
- Let's go, you're about to
make it look easy for us.
Come on.
- Can I get a production
team to hype me up also.
(production team cheers)
- Disrespect this weight real quick.
- About to kiss (indistinguishable)
(upbeat music)
- Nice, you got it.
- Let's go, let's go, let's go man.
Come on.
Get dialed in.
- Go lock in baby.
- Let's get it, let's get it!
Come on, come on!
Get that!
- [Edward] Nice.
- [Brandon] (cheers) come on!
- Up, up, up, up, up!
Get that!
(bell dings)
(all cheering)
- I was confident that he was
gonna get up there with it.
So I was happy to see him keep pushing,
and it gives me something to strive for.
So I haven't really seen
somebody lift weight like that.
(upbeat music)
- This was fun experience.
525, I'm surprised it moved
up a lot faster than I thought
because I didn't work out this whole week.
- I'm surprised by how well he jumped up.
- Yeah.
_ Yeah.
- No, That's what I like about
being fit and working out
that you see other people
and sometimes you judge them
just because how big they are.
I'm big, but I cannot
do weight as they do.
But it's just a
misconception that you think
big muscles are better,
but it's not about that.
It's about your passion and how much time
do you invest on it.
Stand like this.
Mimic me.
Yeah, yeah, pretty good.
And then grab it from here.
(gentle music)
And then the thing is that the bar
needs to be touching
your legs when you go up.
Yeah.
- Touching your legs
- um-hm.
All the way straight.
- Um-hm.
On the same, see?
(production team and contestants clapping)
It's $50.
(all chuckling)